ONE OF THE SENATORS WITH WHOM
SHE MET SAYS THAT HE HAS TESTED
POSITIVE, SORRY TO MIX IT UP.
TED IS LIVE ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> HEY, THERE.
DEMOCRATS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
FORGING AHEAD WITH THIS
CONFIRMATION PROCESS ESPECIALLY
THE NEWS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING THIS
ISN’T GOING TO DELAY ANYTHING.
HERE’S A STATEMENT I’M GOING TO
READ FROM CHUCK SCHUMER.
THE DEMOCRATIC LEADER AND THE
TOP DEMOCRAT ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
THEY SAY, QUOTE, IT’S PREMATURE
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO COMMIT TO A
SCHEDULE WHEN THEY DON’T KNOW
THE POTENTIAL EXPOSURE FROM THE
PRESIDENT’S INFECTION.
REPUBLICAN UTAH SENATOR MIKE LEE
ANNOUNCED HE’S POSITIVE.
HE MET WITH BARRETT ON TUESDAY.
BARRETT IS BEING TESTED DAILY
AND SHE TESTED NEGATIVE.
SO THE JUDICIARY CHIRM LINDSEY
GRAHAM SAYS CONCERN ABOUT
INFECTIONS WON’T SIDELINE THE
BARRETT HEARINGS.
HE TOLD PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT
TODAY BY PHONE.
>> I SAID WE’RE ON TRACK, WE’RE
GOING TO START OCTOBER 12, AND
WE’RE GOING TO WORK HARD TO GET
THIS WONDERFUL CONSERVATIVE
YOUNG LADY, TALENTED BEYOND
BELIEF, AMY BARRETT, ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> NOW IT’S UNCLEAR WHAT THIS
HEARING WOULD LOOK LIKE WITH
THESE HEALTH CONCERNS AT THE
U.S. CAPITOL WOULD THEY HAVE THE
SENATORS BEAM IN REMOTELY LIKE
THEY’VE BEEN WITH OTHER
HEARINGS.
WE HEAR THAT THE OFFICE OF THE
ATTENDING PHYSICIAN IS TESTING
MEMBERS AND STAFF WHO MAY HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED.
THAT’S A KEY ISSUE HERE.
AND, AGAIN, WE TALKED ABOUT
HICCUPS, THIS IS THE TYPE OF
HICCUP THAT COULD DELAY THE
SENATE FROM CONSIDERING THIS
NOMINATION BEFORE THE ELECTION.